Artemis Fowl is a movie for kids but
it's a complicated one with lots going
on there's something for everyone even
adults who will see the movie from a
completely different angle these are the
things only adults notice in Artemis
Fowl younger Thomas Fowler's empowered
to do the amazing things he does through
lack of adult supervision
there aren't any parents around to tell
him to be home by 9:00 alternate wage
violence war against an army of magical
creatures as is the case with many
literary and movie heroes who are also
children Artemis's parents are
noticeably and alarmingly absent the
poor kids beloved mother is long dead
before the events of the movie take
place
there's your dear mother of course who
was a wonderful woman in my opinion and
taken from us far too soon while his
father's absence prompted by his
kidnapping at the hands of a vindictive
fairy queen is the main plus of Artemis
Fowl it stated that Artemis senior
frequently leaves home for long
stretches of time much to artemis
juniors resentment and annoyance in
other words young gar thermos is being
raised by a largely absent single parent
adults will wonder who's looking after
this kid a high maintenance job what
with his genius level abilities and
needs sure that's his bodyguard thumb
avoid Butler but he seems to be more of
an adventure cohort than a parental
figure who does things like take Artemis
to school or make him a meal one of the
highlights of the Artemis Fowl
adaptation is Josh GAD as a witty career
criminal dwarf named mulch Biggums the
character serves as both audience
surrogates and the writer explaining the
film to lab rats and nuanced fantasy
world for newbies while also
participating in the story itself but
God's character is a problematic
narrator plot wise much of the story is
told via interrogation and much of the
story does not involve mulch at all how
does he know the ins and outs of a
complicated story that he didn't witness
firsthand he certainly wasn't in the
room for those tender moments between
Artemis senior and junior for example
this realization could make a savvy
viewer question the entire movie is the
narrator just making stuff up as he goes
along
Owen Cole firs first book in the Artemis
Fowl series hit bookstores in 2001
during a young adult craze and
publishing that made other tales of dark
adventure starring kid and team
protagonists
into blockbuster hits among those
phenomena Harry Potter The Hunger Games
Twilight the Maze Runner and divergent
Hollywood struck while that proverbial
iron was hearts selling all those titles
are more into movies as quickly as
possible but it took Artemis Fowl nearly
20 years to jump from page to screen and
the result is a film that would appear
to adults who have seen a few other y.a
adaptations in their day dated and trite
just who do you think you are I'm
Artemis Fowl
I'm a criminal mastermind so many
elements of the film feel like well-worn
territory at this point if not lifted
whole cloth from other earlier films
March dickham's bears are striking if
not trademark violating resemblance to
Robbie Coltrane's half Giants gamekeeper
Hagrid from the Harry Potter movies
younger Thomas foul dresses in a black
suits and sunglasses and adopts a
nonchalant attitude which has straight
out of men in black
the mysteriously hooded villain seems to
have stepped right out of Star Wars
while the huge war between multiple
magical races is very much a Lord of the
Rings thing and then this Judi Dench who
plays a powerful governmental figure
nothing like the character she's played
in so many James Bond movies Artemis
Fowl is about the clashing of races
fairies elves goblins trolls and other
magical beings factored into the film
but adults watching just might notice an
uncomfortable racial dynamic among the
human characters young guards mrs. Chief
cohort and collaborates her and his
adventures is to mow void Butler in
culphers books the character is off
Eurasian background but in the film
African actor Nonso Anozie landed the
paths thus creating a relationship of
servitude between a character who is
white and one he was a person of color
there aren't many non-white people in
the movie anyway and the most prominent
one is a servants and who dies
temporarily while seeing to the wishes
of his White's child bus
it makes for awkward viewing to say the
least the film's non juvenile audience
will likely include a lot of parents
because at 20:20 theatrical release was
unfortunately impossible Artemis Fowl
debuted on the family-friendly Disney
Plus streaming service it's certain to
be a family movie night selection that
both kids and adults can agree on
particularly fans of the books and
viewers who enjoy fantasy films and
action movies
parents are apt to notice things and
non-breeding humans weren't such as how
kids grow and change relatively rapidly
to that end Artemis Fowl stitch lists
are played by Ferdie ashore grows up
before view asides in some scenes Asher
appears pint-sized and baby-faced
while in others he looks like a tween in
the early stages of adolescence and then
still other sections of the film he
seems to be a teenager
of course Artemis Fowl like nearly all
films was not shot in sequential order
meaning Shore looks completely different
from one scene to the next in a
five-minute segments he made
from older to younger - not quite
dissolved then back to little once more
that's a poster most kids movies
released in the last couple of decades
Artemis Fowl this almost completely
devoid of cheap easy and pointless
pop-culture references refreshingly
nobody tabs or sings last year's song of
the summer uses an emoji or mentions
Facebook Artemis Fowl is concerned with
the action at hand and that's has more
to do with the history and the thousand
years of fighting between humans and
fairies than it does with the presidents
and the frivolities of the world that
says there are a couple of jokes about
rock stars of the late 20th century when
mulch sits in prison he passes a time by
listening to tunes on a music box he
stole from Holly short he rocks out to
foreigners 1984 power ballad I want to
know what lovers annoying a cell mates
the guy he's speaking to as a speaking
voice that sounds just like that of glam
rock pioneer David Bowie mulch brings up
a singer again in conversation with
ferry commander Julius roots has anyone
ever told you you're like David Bowie if
David Bowie were a fairy so essentially
you're David Bowie adding to the joke
mojo identifies Bowie as the magical
creature millions believed he was do you
think the humans will ever find out he
was one of us check out one of our
newest videos racier plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you